they've been called the worst floods in
pakistan's history by the country's
prime minister
one third of the nation's land is under
water
so what has caused these floods to be so
bad and how have people been affected
for the best of sky news videos
subscribe to our youtube channel just
tap the button below
an estimated 33 million people have been
impacted by these floods and over 1
500 people have died each of pakistan's
four provinces have been affected but
the southern states of sindh and
balochistan have been hit the hardest
roads bridges and key infrastructure
have been left underwater
these satellite images show towns and
cities completely submerged
communities have been totally cut off
and left without food and drinking water
but these floods will have lasting
effects to come
many crops have been totally wiped out
including 45 of cotton pakistan's
planning minister says that it will cost
around 10 billion dollars to rebuild the
country now pakistan has experienced
flooding before but not to this extent
so why is it so bad this time
the indus river which runs through the
country from the north in the himalayas
down into the arabian sea is actually
prone to flooding in the months of july
and august
but this is unprecedented and one reason
why is rising temperatures now pakistan
is home to more than 7 000 glaciers more
than any country in the world outside
the north and south poles now these
rising temperatures are causing the
glaciers to melt forming glacial lakes
around 3 000 have already formed and
officials are warning that 33 of them
are close to bursting
a second factor is pakistan's monsoon
season which started earlier than normal
this year it's been dubbed the monster
monsoon this monster is something we
have never seen it typically lasts for
one and a half months in july and august
but the intensity frequency and duration
of rain has been changing this monsoon
season is different this time it's been
unrelenting no break eight weeks monsoon
season should have stopped by end of
july sindh province has had nearly eight
times more rain than normal this year
and balochistan province has had five
times its normal level
pakistan is the eighth most vulnerable
country in the world to extreme weather
and melting glaciers caused by rising
temperatures can be attributed to global
warming in april the mercury and sins
navarb hit a whopping 50 degrees celsius
it is an entirely new level of climate
led catastrophe pakistan has said it's
at the ground zero of climate change
despite their carbon footprint being
less than one percent of global
emissions and the country's planning
minister has said richer countries have
a responsibility to help the nation
because they've caused climate change
pakistan's government has been widely
criticized for ignoring the urgency of
climate change and not building enough
preventative infrastructure in 2010
massive floods killed around 2 000
people but since no plans have been
implemented to prevent future floods and
now newly formed glacial lakes have
become tourist attractions developers
have been given permission to build
hotels on the banks of swollen rivers
with disastrous effects
the floods could hardly have come at a
worse time for a country already in
turmoil pakistan's elected prime
minister imran khan was ousted in april
leading to political turmoil inflation
and employment are high and the repeal
is depreciating
as well as difficulty distributing aid
and reaching cut-off communities there
are now fears of water-borne diseases
spreading
because the water simply isn't draining
away as for climate change the number of
days of predicted rainfall in pakistan
are set to rise massively
even a limit of 1.5 degrees celsius on
global warming by 2050 will still mean a
third of pakistan's glaciers melting
[Music]
you